شيطان نربطها الاتصال مع الدكتور سمير
التقي الباحث في معهد الشرق الاوسط في
واشنطن اهلا بك سيدي ما هي رسائل هذه
الزياره المفاجئه في هذا التوقيت بالذات
للرئيس الاوكراني الى واشنطن
متعدده بعضها موجه طبعا لروسيا لتقول بان
الولايات المتحده ملتزمه ولكي يفهم بروتين
بان الولايات المتحده لا ترغب من جهه
بالسلام مباشر بين العسكريين ولكنها
ملتزمه
بعمليا هزيمه في روسيا في اوكرانيا
واعتقد انه بالمقابل هناك رسائل
للامريكيين هناك بعض الدول الاوروبيه
الاوروبيه المترديده هناك بعض اذا همم
يرسل هذه الرساله الاوروبيين يقول نحن
اصبحنا الان في مرحله ما بعد غزوه
اوكرانيا العالم سينقسم وينبغي اخراج
روسيا همم من همم النظام العالمي ال- ال-
الاقتصادي ولذلك في هذا المجال همم سيكون
همم الرساله مهمه هناك ايضا رساله لاهميه
للشعب الامريكي بالذات اعتقد انه يجري همم
اجماع واسع النقاط عابر للاحزاب فيما
يتعلق بالقضيه الاوكرانيه واا اعتقد بانه
سيصعد جدا على اي رئيس مقبل ان يبدل بشكل
رئيسي هذا التوجه زلينسكي اصبح شخصيه ااه
امريكيه يعني يعتز بها الامريكيون ويدهش
احيان بها الامريكيون لذلك نقل
الراي العام الامريكي الى مرحله تبني
القضيه الاوكرانيه هي قضيه
هذه الفكره نقل تفضلت بالقول بان الهدف من
بين الرسائل ونقل هذه الفكره للامريكيين
او تسويقها تعالت الاصوات بعد الانتخابات
الاخيره التي تقول بان العدو ليس اوكرانيا
وانما العدو هي الصين وان الولايات
المتحده انما تنفق وقتا وجهدا ويعني
مجهودا عسكريا وعتادا في بلد لا يشكل
بالنسبه للولايات المتحده اهميه او اولى
الاولويات برايك هل ما زال هذا النقاش
مطروح اليوم في واشنطن
في امريكا سيبقى تبقى هذه النقاشات مطروحه
ولكن الى اي مدى تكتسب عزما هذا هو السؤال
الرئيسي في اعتقادي ان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه اصبحت ملتزمه موضوعيا بغض النظر
عن الرئيس الذي سياتي في اعتقادي بعد
الرئيس باندا فيما يتعلق بان بهذا التطور
الاستراتيجي الذي يعيد على اما عن الصين
فاعتقد الموضوع مختلف الموضوع ليس هناك
الان حرب تجريد ضد الصين ولا تنوي
الولايات المتحده ان تشن حرب بسيط ولكن
اعتقد بان بالمقابل الان او ربى بكاملها
امريكا تكتشف حاجتها الكبيره لاوضه وانها
عمليا تشكل الظهير الاساسي الاستراتيجي
والصخره التي ينبغي الاستناد اليها هذا
التطور ايضا في الفكر السياسي الامريكي
هام جدا بعد ما طرحه الرئيس ترامب من
المواقف معي التاليه
الاصداء هنا في اوروبا في ظل هذا الشتاء
الذي يتخوف منه الاوروبيون وقد يكون قارسا
على البعض البعض يقول بان الرابح الاكبر
في هذه المواجهه غير المباشره هي الولايات
المتحده والحرب لا تجري على اراضيها فهل
نستشف من هذا بان هناك ثمه انقسام او
اصوات اوروبيه على الاقل المانيه فرنسيه
فلنقل تدعم او تدفع في اتجاه الحوار مع
روسيا وانهاء هذه الحرب التي تؤلم
الاوروبيين بالدرجه الاولى
اوروبا اختار جيرانها وهي تستمر في الحروب
بهذه النوع من الحروب منذ 500 عام مع
المانيا وروسيا وفرنسا وهي الاعمده
الرئيسيه بريطانيا المشكله هي قضيه ايقاف
هذا العدوان واعتقد ان ان برلين مهدده
لزياده القطر الذي تهدد
لان الموضوع سيشكل القلب لموازين القوى
والقلب لهذا التطور مقراطي الكبير اذا
كانت اوروبا راغبه في المحافظه على
الديمقراطيتها بعد الاختراقات
الاستراتيجيه التي تمت في اوروبا من قبل
بوتين للساعه لتفكيك وايقاظ القوميه
والعصبيه الوطنيه ضد التكامل الاوروبي في
اعتقادي اوروبا تحسم خياراتها بالرغم انه
تبقى هناك اصوات ولكن من الناحيه العمليه
نعم او ربطه قررت ان تضحي تعتبر نفسها
جزءا من الحرب على على روسيا بانها حرمت
نفسها من التدفئه وهذه التضحيه كبيره
بعدها اعتقد ولكن هذا قرار سياسي بالنسبه
للقرارات السياسيه راينا بان الاوروبيين
يتجهون الى فرض حزمه اخرى همم التاسعه
ربما على روسيا همم راينا اليوم بان هناك
خبر تدشين بوتين
يربط مباشره الغاز اذا يورد الغاز الى
الصين هل نحن امام توليفه دوليه جديده
حرب الاستنزاف اطري تكتلات اقليميه
لا اعتقد ذلك لان اللقاء الاخير الذي تم
بين الرئيس بعيدا وسجن بينك في اندونيسيا
كان لقاء الناجحا هذا الانبوب الذي يدشنه
بوتين سيستغرق ما لا يقل عن سبع سنوات لكي
يمدد ويفعل وهناك يعني تساؤلات كبيره حول
قدره روسيا بعد ان خرج الخبراء الاجانب من
توتال
وغيرها من من الشركات وهلي بورتن همم بعد
ان خرجت من روسيا هناك شاب كبير بقدره
روسيا على انجاز عمليا اعاده تاهيل الابار
في منطقه سيبيريا الشديده البروده التي
تنفجر فيها الانابيب ولذلك تقنيه هو
التحدي ولكن لا اتصور بانها همم الولايات
المتحده او الغرب اساسا يعني مهتم بتعطيش
همم روسيا بمعنى ان يحرمها ولكنه يريد ان
يحرمها من القدره على اعاده انتاج
عسكريتها واجهتها
ولذلك اعتقد في كل الاحوال
الغاز روسي سيذهب الى مكان ما بعضه سيغلق
بلا شك ان على التقديرات بان العام المقبل
روسيا لن تستطيع ان تصدر ذات الكميات على
الاطلاق لان الانابيب تتجمد وتنفجر لا
يستطيعون انخزن فيها ولذلكم يبحثون عن اي
طريقه للتصدير حتى بالبحر والبحر اصبح
ايضا غير ميسور بشكل جدي لذلك هناك صعوبات
كبيره يمكن نناقشه بشكل منفرد لا اعتقد ان
التدشين سيكون له اسرره على همم وضع السوق
الطاقه بالنسبه لروسيا وقدرتها على تصوير
كميات المطلوبه هي اصلا من روسيا تصدر
حوالي 500,000 الى مليون الى الى الى
الصين شكرا دكتور سمير الثقيل الباحث في
مركز الشرق الاوساط من واشنطن شكرا جزيلا
لك